everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm they're gonna be starting
our coverage on the 2014 rapid World
Chess Championships and the blitz
championships as well if you're not too
familiar with the format and the
tournament itself I'll kind of break it
down for you on Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday they play the rapid
championships they play five matches
today each of those matches is 15
minutes plus 10 seconds per move so if
you move very very quickly you actually
increase your time you'll have more than
15 minutes on Thursday and Friday they
play about 10 matches a day and that's
gonna be in the blitz format so you're
gonna be looking at about 3 minutes per
game per player and they do get a 10
second additional time advantage for
each move that they make so again if you
move very very quickly it keeps you from
losing all of your time so again there's
gonna be a lot of matches per day I'm
gonna try to take some that I think are
interesting some of the bigger names in
the tournament that you may be familiar
with and so in the first match today
we're gonna be looking at this is from
round one White's gonna be played by
Eduardo Benelli he's a grandmaster from
Venezuela definitely a very very strong
player really likes the English opening
and I don't cover many games with the
English opening so I thought it'd be
pretty cool to show him and he's playing
my favorite player in this particular
tournament Nakamura from the United
States of America my kind of dark horse
to win the tournament very very
accomplished a fast chess player so I
think he's gonna do very very well in
this tournament so we'll go ahead and
get started
white starts out with Knight to f3 pawn
to d5 and then a pawn to c4 again this
is the English opening that we kind of
talked about then black that decides to
decline this pawn right here so he plays
pawn here to c6 pawn here to e39 f6
Knight c3 simple development move from
both sides nothing too crazy pawn a6
Queen here - see - it's really
interesting to see different players but
usually no one's gonna get too crazy
early on especially in round 1
we have so many round they have 15
rounds are gonna be playing so no reason
to get too crazy right away pawn here to
g6 getting ready to fianchetto on the
King side and then castle pawn here to
deed
or very similar to kind of a Queen's
Gambit playing pawn here to d4 and then
Queen here or pawn here to c4 Bishop
here to d7 pawn to be three the pawn
takes right here on c4 and white has a
few different options myself I were to
take him with my bishop here on c4 nice
little outpost for this bishop although
it could be kicked off right away but it
is attacking this square here on f7 very
easy to play in the particular game
Benelli decided to go ahead and take
with his pawn here on c4 which is fine
if you do this you are going to be
playing this rook here to b1 send the
open file on the B file right here so
that's gonna be kind of his game plan
and that's fine as well both sides that
I think are pretty equal pawn here to c5
instead of taking white decides to go
ahead and push forward with d5 and I
really like this because this does gain
some space especially in any chess game
space is very important but especially
in a rapid or a blitz game as your
opponent is strapped on time and really
people just make a lot of mistakes even
at the highest level they make mistakes
if you can kind of squeeze them not give
them a ton of space a lot of times
they'll crumble under that and so again
this d5 move makes a lot of sense from
white compared to exchanging pawns off
material giving up this D file there's
just no reason for what to do that right
now
pawn here to b5 a great move from
nakamori this is kind of the best way to
kind of chip away at the defense this
pawn here on c4 is kind of defending
this and this immediately
counter-attacks that on the Queen side
of the board Bishop here - B - opening
up the door when this Knight moves to
kind of control and attack this long
diagonal right here castle on the Kings
side and then pawn takes on a b5 and
then we have the retake right here and
then White has a few options he picked
the right choice and that is taking with
his bishop here on b5 but is interesting
how some of the top players in the world
play because it would be very very easy
for you to look at this and say okay
I'll go ahead and take with my knight
right here it's completely fine it
really doesn't matter
if I take with my bishop or my knight
both ways I have protection from the
other minor piece but the game is very
very different this particular case now
the bishop can come here to f5 attacking
this Queen once the Queen moves all of a
sudden Black has two attackers on the
square here on the five so you know the
Queen can come here to b3
the knight takes here on d5 all of a
sudden this is not looking as good for
white he's kind of lost control of the
center of the board Black has a very
active center he doesn't have his bishop
now right here on f5 attacking the
center with both of his bishops if we
compare this just to again go back in
this board state with the bishop taking
here on b5 the bishop can't just come
down here to b5 anymore or to f5 all of
a sudden white can kind of block it with
this pawn here to e4 he has his knight
protecting it as Queen protecting it all
of a sudden that this is no longer a
good move for black so the small little
difference in this move also this Knight
is now protecting this pawn here on d5
as well so although it looks about the
same since both minor pieces are
protecting this this bishop taking here
on b5 is a much better plane and it's
always fun to watch these high-level
plays being made with such little time
for them to think black now plays Knight
to a6 and then we see castle on the King
side I really like this position pawn to
e4 I think it's just a lot stronger
solidifies the center of the board he
does need some protection on the square
on d5 he can always castle later he
doesn't have to cast him right away
I think it was just a little bit
stronger than castling on the King side
once he does knock more immediately
plays Knight here to b4 and he has a lot
of attackers he has both of his Knights
has his queen attacking this square here
on d5 so it's gonna be very very
difficult for Eduardo to kind of hold on
to this pawn on d5 decides to go ahead
and swing is queen over here to e 2
doesn't want it again that's being
attacked right now by this knight so
definitely wants to get it out of there
the knight immediately takes here on a
d5 gobbling up some of the
material it doesn't have to worry too
much about the the center of the board
right now so that's definitely going to
be a good thing for black as far as we
look at it we now see the roof swing
over here to d1 trying to control this
long open file the night's going to take
we're gonna have an exchange right here
very interesting both sides have their
bishop pair on board so it's an open
board state meaning there's not a lot of
ponds clogging at the center of the
board so this is going to be good for
bishops just come to keep in mind the
Queen's gonna move again is being
attacked by this rook right here pawn
here to a4 anytime you have passed pawns
they're really meant to be pushed
especially it's on the edge over here
this is gonna be a great place to kind
of start to push because it's very hard
for your opponent to control this air on
the board and really focus on these
pawns on the outlier if you have a pawn
here on c5 it'll be easier for your
opponent to control the chair of the
board and just keep an eye on this
squares in this particular case the pawn
here on c5 now the Bishop to b7
controlling this long diagonal right
here and then a few different options
from light you know again if we kind of
look at it both sides have a pretty even
game white maybe have a small advantage
but not too much a few things he could
do you know Benelli could try pushing
forward with a 5 this makes sense he
does have both his Bishop and his rook
protecting it so past pawns are meant to
be pushed he could try h3 potentially
keeping this knight coming here to g4
although it would be difficult for this
night to do a whole heck of a lot you
could always play Queenie er to be 2
that's definitely an option lining up
this barrel right here to attack and
control this long file he chose another
option which you know seems fine as well
I guess the rook swinging over here to
c1 giving a little bit more
reinforcement also if this bishop moves
they'll be able to control this C file
right here Nakamura decides to bring his
own rook over here to c8 which makes
sense Queen here to c4 kind of lining up
on this pond right here also attacking
the square on f7 which again is still a
weakness as it's the only
square right now being protected by the
king then we have the bishop take on f3
definitely interesting move I thought
from Nakamura as I saw this giving your
opponent the bishop pair and losing the
bishop pair for yourself
it's kind of weird again especially in
an open game like this the pawns going
to recapture yes it does give his
opponent a you know doubled pawns here
on the F file but giving them a double
Bishop hair is definitely just difficult
to deal with so not sure I would have
done that but again Nakamura is a much
stronger player than me so in the heat
of the moment we'll go ahead and say
it's not the worst thing ever
pawn here to e6 Bishop here to a d4 nice
little move knowing that the pawn cannot
take this bishop the Queen would go down
and then black would definitely lose in
the exchange of material right here so
nice little move from White's Knights
coming in here to d5
and then the Queen's just going to take
here on a c5 getting some material
advantage in the game we kind of look at
it White has five pawns of material
black has four all the white does again
have the double pawns but white also has
the double bishop pair in the opening
game so white has a small advantage but
not huge advantage on board Queen back
here to d8 and then we have the Queen
come back here to a3 Queen here to g5
getting involved into the action again
this King is a little bit unsafe because
this pawn is recaptured here on f3 so
then we have the King come back here at
h1 again that we're gonna kind of do a
little dance over here the bishop comes
back for a discovered attack if he wants
it now the bishops gonna come up here to
f8 attacking this Queen here on a3 the
roofs gonna swing up here to see eights
and then after the rook recaptures both
sides trying to gain some ground but no
one really has a clear advantage on
board white eventually will look to push
his pawn up on the a file but it's not
clear how he's going to gain a huge
advantage to actually be able to do that
now we have the Queen come down here to
h4 now the King's gonna come up here to
a g2 again attacking the King the king
comes back we're gonna do a few moves
very interesting in the particular
gainer if we come back to this
particular case we already have a two
fold repetition if you repeat the same
moves for three times it's actually a
drawl now if you look at and Ward owes
position he his first match big
tournament he's playing Nakamura one of
the top ten players in the world
definitely one of the top rapid chess
players in the world he can pretty much
just take a draw here but he said you
know what I'm the white pieces it's
about even right now but I'm gonna go
for the win and instead of taking the
threefold repetition decided to go ahead
and play Bishop here to a6 saying no
draw for me I want to play out could
definitely cost him as again I think
Nakamura is just a much better player
than him but valiant effort on his part
to go ahead and try to play for the win
we now see black bring his Bishop to d6
and Nakamura looking for the quick check
made here on h2 although it is a rapid
at game usually don't see a grandmaster
actually fall for something like this I
think pawn to f4 is just the easiest and
cleanest way to go about blocking this I
can't really find a lot of ways that
this goes bad for whites in the game
though decides to play King here to g2
which i think is pretty weak kind of
opens up the door for Nakamura you know
he's just building up a lot of his
presence on the King side and the King
coming up more closer to the the Queen
just seems a little odd to me but the
Queen's gonna come down capture here on
h2 now the King comes back here to f1
we're swinging over here to be eights
Bishop here to b5 nice little outpost
it's gonna be very difficult for black
to do a whole heck of a lot here with
this Bishop in this pawn here but that's
completely fine he's gonna start forcing
the action on the King side he does have
now this past pollen on h5 he can start
to push it down his opponents throat he
doesn't have a very active Queen so it's
gonna be very difficult for white to
have too much safety going on we now see
King here to e2 nice little bubble he
starts to worry a little bit but not
right now King here to g2 Bishop here to
H AIDS
getting ready for a checkmate
potentially with Queen here to g7 so
something that black has to deal with
he plays Bishop here to f8 it's good and
bad yes that kind of stops any immediate
checkmate but also you just don't want
your bishop to have to play defense duty
and again that was definitely one of the
big pieces that Nakamura was kind of
using to attack his opponent all of a
sudden that's off the game and and
blacks attack doesn't look nearly as
strong as it did before now the bishop
comes back here to e5 rook swinging over
here to a eight interesting move it's
not doing too much he could have also
tried to bring his rook here to c8 and
then down here to c5 and really
solidified again he does have his Bishop
on f8 kind of protecting that so you
could have just kind of locked down this
entire thing right here that works for
me over here to a I think it's a little
bit passive he now has defense duty with
his bishop he also has defense duty with
his rook here on eight so a very
defensive minded Nakamura right now
going into the in game of this chess
game Bishop here to c6 a very aggressive
move from our guardo attacking both of
these pieces after the rook comes down
white decides to go ahead and in take
after after the pawn recaptures a nice
nice move here with Queen here to b6
it's threatening a few things first and
foremost the most important the Nakamura
has to deal with is he's threatening the
rook here on a5 that's kind of an
obvious to everyone watching but he's
also threatening Queen to f6 and then
from here Queen here to h8 is going to
be checkmate so Nakamura really has to
figure out how he can go about doing
this now he does have kind of an out
here you can always take with his rook
here to a4 but then you know the Queen's
gonna come over here but that's fine
because Nakamura can now bring his rook
down here check the bishops now gonna
come back we can make even exchange back
here yes black is kind of down a little
bit of material but again he's only down
as far as you know the rook and the
bishop but he does have an extra pawn
it's gonna be very difficult in my
opinion for Nakamura to
lose this interesting interesting move
in the eggs in the game I'm not sure of
Nakamura just didn't see the rook being
attacked over here or just was really
too concerned with this Queen coming
here to f6 but in the game he played
Queen here to g5 huge blunder pretty
much allowing his rook to go down very
easily a bishop coming here to f4
attacking the Queen the queen is forced
to move and then the rook falls here on
a5 so from here it's it's a pretty quick
defeat again we have two grandmasters
although Nakamura is much higher as far
as a ranking it doesn't matter who's
playing this position White's usually
going to win because he's just up a
massive amount of material nakamura
makes you know run for trying to gobble
up some material but you know ward oh
Benelli still has more pieces on board
and again it doesn't even matter if
nakamura tries to push on the King side
that there's just no real hope here why
it's okay exchanging the Queens off the
board this would be fine for him as fast
as he can get down all material on the
board it's gonna be easy for him to win
we see a few last-ditch effort moves
from both sides but then eventually we
just see the Queen come back here to d3
there's no other moves from Nakamura
it's really doing this position the
[ __ ] be R and D sticks kind of stops
any momentum for this pawn here on the
Kings side to push forward and then
Nakamura just down too much material so
decides to go ahead and resign in this
game so kind of disappointing my my
favorite to when the tournament goes
down in round 1 he has 14 rounds to make
up for its but definitely an interesting
match for Eduardo Benelli again a great
Venezuelan player utilizing the English
opening he's very familiar with it and
in a rapid setting he did extremely
extremely well so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this commentary kind of enjoyed
some fast chess compared to some of the
longer games that we've been covering
for a while here
definitely make sure you check out on
the website at s website comm for
additional commentary on other games and
then again everyday I'll be having more
games from both the rapid and the
blessed blitz championships thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video